start with the thief in Chief dad on
Friday he finally acknowledged his
seventh granddaughter Hunter's daughter
with London Roberts this after avoiding
her like she was Kamala Harris
for some reason it came in an exclusive
statement to People magazine making it
their best scoop since they've
discovered that love child I had with
Angela Lansbury
she was a hell of an animal
but here's what uh he said to a Ducey
back in 2019.
Mr Vice President I'm wondering if you
have a comment on this report and Court
filing out of Arkansas that your son
Hunter just made you uh grandfather
again no that's a private matter I have
no comments
you're a good man thank you guys this is
all the time we have classy
yeah classy like denying a kid's
existence for four years